I had a feeling at that time that I
would do anything to get a shot anything
that is evident yeah I mean and there is
a I'll tell you the feeling that I had
what draws me what drew me to this and
everything else I've done are the
characters first who they are who was
the person behind that mask of a face
who are these people
how do they move what do they say I mean
exactly what do they say and what are
they all about and when I met egan and
grosso I realized that Egan was all
about obsession and that's how this case
was made by an obsessed cop who didn't
give a damn about anything that got in
his way Chris and that's exactly how
Eddie Egan was I didn't make the film to
celebrate a Teague Egan that there are
moments in the film that are obviously
racist but I can tell you that Egan was
not a racist this was an act that he did
to survive in the street and a lot of
cops were killed that didn't have a
persona like Egan had developed but I
there was a book not long ago written by
the great French filmmaker jean-luc
Godard and the book was called
everything is cinema and that's how I
felt then everything was cinema
everywhere that I would point the camera
I felt this was going to be interesting
you know the end these characters
weren't going to be doing stuff that you
didn't expect and I I would go to any
lengths to get the shot because
everything was cinema that's how the
filmmakers of my generation felt Francis
Coppola and Peter
Bogdanovic and others who came later we
had no idea then how much money our
films or any other films made we didn't
know how much money
Gone with the Wind had made and we
didn't care we used to talk about things
like whose vision of cinema will survive
Gianluca died or federico fellini you
know because Fellini was all about
surrealism and beautiful framing and
beautiful lighting and God I was about
grabbing the shot off the street and
jump cuts and handheld cameras and I
we'd have arguments about that and I
that's all we would talk about we never
read in the papers like you do now how
much money this film made on Thursday or
for the weekend which my great friend
the editor of the LA Times is here
tonight davon Maharaja and davon I wish
you could be the editor of The Times in
those days when they just wrote about
cinema in that box office and now all
they care about is box office that's
that's okay
because that's what drives the business
but it didn't then and well I think I
don't know what side of that argument I
was on but I think Gaddar is the one who
survived because almost everything you
see even on television owes something to
go die jump cuts quick cuts like you do
in Mission Impossible you know guilty
yeah every seven seconds the shot
changes and in in the days when I was
making films like this it we tried to
hold the shot as long as possible we
didn't want to cut we only cut to go to
the next scene or if some guy was
standing way over there
we had a there's no way to get him in
the same frame